>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> John Cole: Welcome to
the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the director of the Center for
the Book in Library of Congress,
of which the Young
Readers Center is a part,
even though we say the Young
Readers Center, as does the Center
for the Book, belongs
to the whole Library.
And, one of our jobs is to
promote books and reading
and literacy in libraries.
And, since the Young Readers
Center opened in 2009,
we can say that we
are now doing this
for everybody, people of all ages.
And, the Library of Congress
itself is a wonderful institution,
but it's 18 to 20 reading
rooms, as you probably know,
have traditionally since the
late 19th century have been open
for 16 or older.
And, after -- and in the period when
I came for a while it went up to 18
and older, then came
back down to 16.
And, now over -- open to everyone,
as Thomas Jefferson
would truly appreciate.
The Center for the Book itself was
created in 1977, by Daniel Boorstin
when he was Librarian of Congress,
and he felt it was important
for this -- the Library
to have a place and also
in particular have programs that
reached to the general audience
that promoted books and reading.
We weren't even talking about
literacy in 1977, believe it or not.
Now, we say that our goal is to
stimulate public interest in books,
reading, literacy, and libraries.
We have a special literacy
awards program,
and also to encourage the study
of the role of books, reading,
and literacy and libraries
in our culture.
And, it's in that sense
we're so happy to be --
be able to present
Leonard Marcus today.
Leonard has -- I think many of
you know, Leonard is a expert
in all phases of the
children's book world.
And, we're very lucky to have him.
What we're going to do today is to
have a presentation from Leonard
of which he has prepared
specially for us.
But, in addition, we will have
a question and answer period.
And, I know some of
you have been part
of the Lewis Carroll celebration
going on at the Library of Congress,
and have already been
up to the Rare Book
and Special Collections Division,
or where there is a display
of the rare books, copies, and
various editions of "Alice".
And, others of you, I know,
participated in this two-for-one,
this double-header of a
celebration, in part starting
with our Young Readers Center
of -- last Friday, when,
those of you who weren't
able to join us,
there was a special
dress-up story time featuring
"Alice in Wonderland."
All costumed children were invited
and did join in an Alice parade
on the first two floors of
the Thomas Jefferson Building.
Inside the Young Readers
Center, and I just took Leonard
down to see the Young
Readers Center.
He actually, the last time
he came, he gave a talk
for the Center for the Book.
We were still in construction
down there.
So, it's been a while,
but he was impressed
with the wonderful family
atmosphere and the developments
of the Younger Readers Center,
which is on the ground
floor in this building.
And, if you haven't seen
it, I hope you will.
And, I should say that -- a
special thank you, really,
to the head of the
Young Readers Center,
Karen Chafey [assumed spelling], who
is here, and also to her assistant,
Kaheed Mohamed [assumed spelling].
They really have entered
into this spirit
of this Lewis Carroll
celebration, and in fact,
they've pulled their boss into
it in many different ways.
I have an interest in the
history of the Library of Congress
and it was Karen who actually went
to an earlier talk that Leonard gave
at the Rosinback Museum in
Philadelphia about "Alice"
and came back excited to remind
me of the small collection --
connection of the Library
of Congress had in helping
to return the original
manuscript of "Alice" back
to the British Library
where it is on display.
It happens that last week I was
lucky enough to be in London,
and lucky enough to have a day --
a good part of a day
at the British Library
and I had a wonderful time
looking at their "Alice
in Wonderland" exhibit,
which has been up.
Many of you have probably
seen it, I hope.
And, to see their special
Alice's Popup Gift Shop,
and also to come back with a
copy of what they are selling,
which is their new edition of
"Alice's Adventures Underground",
which is the actual facsimile.
And, the store, but I'm not going
into it because we have to get
to Leonard fast because we only
have between one and two o'clock
to return to the Rare Book Division
to see the rest of the display.
But, here is how the return -- it's
a long store, but the -- Alice is --
the manuscript was
sold to an American,
and eventually found
its way back to England,
and this is when the
heirs were short of money.
And, there's a description
of this in the --
this little book that
I'll just read,
and then I'll quickly
introduce Leonard.
And, it's talking about how the
manuscript was sold in 1928, of --
to an American, and the -- of --
then it went on, put up for sale
at Sotheby's and went to a
donor who then died in 1946.
Following the death
of its American owner,
the original "Alice" manuscript,
depicted here with these
wonderful illustrations
by Lewis Carroll came
up again at auction.
Rosinback, Dr. Rosinback, bought it,
and this time for 50,000 dollars.
Initially it was 28,000 dollars.
A plan was then hatched, and
here's how this plan was described
in this book.
I know it is -- we -- other
of us have different version.
It was hashed out by the prominent
bibliophile Leslie Rosenwald.
You were in the Rosenwald Room if
you were up at the exhibit earlier,
who persuaded a group
of wealthy benefactors
at the famous little book should
be returned to its own country
as a gesture of thanks
for the British people's
gallantry in World War Two.
Six, November, 1948, the Library of
Congress, Luther Evans at the time,
sailed for England on the Queen
Elizabeth, taking the manuscript
with him, and occasionally
sleeping with it under his pillow.
On 12 November, he presented it to
the British Museum as an expression
of thanks to a noble people
who kept Hitler at bay
for a long period, single-handed.
The Archbishop of Canterbury, who
accepted it on behalf of the nation,
proclaimed this gesture as
an unsullied and innocent act
in a distracted and sinful world,
a sentiment which would have
appealed to the story's creator.
Now, Leonard is -- has
prepared a special talk --
illustrated talk for us today.
Of those of you who don't know
Leonard may know him as an author
of many books related to the
worlds of children's books.
He in particular has taken
an interest in recent times
in illustrators and
illustrated children's books,
and this is my last way
to introduce Leonard.
This is the book that really helped
us at the Library of Congress.
This is called "Show Me a Story,
Why Picture Books Matter",
and why it mattered to us was, we
had just created the Children's --
the young people's center in 2009.
This book was published in
2012, I had already met Leonard.
He was talking about his
work with illustrators,
and another important
project for the Center
for the Book is the
National Book Festival.
And, we were just moving --
moving in a serious way toward
expanding it, toward something
that was also new at the
time, graphic novels.
And, one of the wonderful
parts of this particular book,
which I brought for Leonard to sign
and then I rediscovered
he'd already signed it,
was that it has the biographies,
and it really helped introduce
at least John Cole to the world
of children's book
illustration in an important way.
We're lucky to have
Leonard Marcus here today.
He's prepared something for us.
He'll tell us about it, and join me
in welcoming children's
book authority
and advocate, Leonard Marcus.
[ Applause ]
>> Leonard Marcus:
Well, good afternoon.
It's really an honor to be
here and see so many people.
Since we're in the
Library of Congress,
I want to just mention two American
associations with the beginnings
of "Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland."
Lewis Carroll improvised the
story for the three little girls,
the daughters of the
dean of Christchurch,
Oxford where he was a
teacher on July 4, 1862.
And, he intended to publish the
book exactly three years later
on the fourth of July in 1865.
Actually a few copies were
printed, but then the illustrator,
John Tenniel, saw how
poorly the reproduction
of his line work had
been and he insisted
that the printing be
scrapped and started over.
Carroll and Tenniel and
their publisher, MacMillan,
came up with a novel solution.
They decided to send the unbound
pages from that first printing
to America because the Americans
wouldn't know the difference
between good printing and bad.
So, when -- result of that was
that "Alice" was actually published
in the US a little bit
before it was published here.
And, the British edition came
out, not in 1865, but 1866.
So, we are actually celebrating
the 150th anniversary of "Alice"
in the British fashion today.
So, I'm going to talk about Lewis
Carroll as a man, as a thinker,
and as someone who
was influenced by one
of the great countercultural
movements of the Western --
modern Western world, Romanticism,
and as an influencer of another one
of those movements, surrealism.
"Alice" chronologically
falls right in --
smack in the middle between those
two developments in Western culture.
To look at Lewis Carroll,
you would never guess
that he was any sort
of revolutionary.
It's hard to imagine him with a
beret and a [inaudible] cigarette,
which is how you would
imagine the Surrealists.
But, in fact, just about everything
that he did involved
questioning received wisdom.
Certainly as a writer for children,
he came up with another way
of thinking about childhood
and approaching the business
of making a story for children
than had really been
seen before in print.
That implied a different
understanding
of what children were really like.
In other realms, he was one of the
very first amateur photographers,
and one of the very best.
And, by all indications,
he was someone
who challenged his own
father's sense of what it meant
to be a religious person.
His father was an archdeacon
in the Church of England.
He trained to -- to be and
became a deacon of the church.
But, unlike his father he
thought that theater was --
that the stage was as good a
place for truth to be spoken
as the pulpit, whereas many of
the more orthodox Christians
like his own father
rejected theater out of hand.
So, he was constantly
rethinking what he'd been taught,
and that in some ways is the
message if -- of "Alice" itself.
This is a book, very, very
well-known book in England
with which the young Lewis
Carroll, who's real name
of course was Charles Dodson,
would have grown up with.
It was a book that was meant to
guide children to be industrious,
hard-working, well-behaved.
This is the most famous rhyme
from that book, and those of you
who aren't familiar with the rhyme
but find that it sounds familiar,
it's because it's one of the poems
that Lewis Carroll
parodied in "Alice".
These of course are
emblematic of industry.
Lewis Carroll was the third of
11 children, the oldest son,
and he relished the role
of older brother while he
and his siblings were growing up.
He did magic shows for them.
He dressed up with a turban.
He had a little puppet theater where
he was the impresario of shows.
And, he wrote poems and made funny
drawings like the one you're looking
at right now to be
published in quotes,
in a magazine that only
circulated within the family.
So, he was in fact very industrious,
but in ways that were very different
from the ones that Isaac Watts
had, you know, advocated.
Here is a rhyme from one of
those family magazine poems.
Let me read to you.
This is not complete,
but you'll get the gist.
"I have a fairy by my side,
which says I must not sleep.
When once in pain I loudly cried,
it said, 'You must not weep.
If, full of mirth, I smile and grin,
it says, 'You must not laugh.'
When once I wished to drink some gin
it said, 'You must not quaff.'" And,
it goes on, and then
it ends with a moral,
as all good children's
book were meant to do.
His moral is, you mustn't.
So, he was, as a 13 year
old, which is how old he was
when he wrote this, he was already
engaged in parody in a particular --
poking fun and taking symbols and
people of authority down a notch.
He was showing a great deal
of independence of mind.
And, he was urging that on his
younger brothers and sisters.
He grew up to become an admirer
of the poetry of William Blake.
And, Blake, of course, had a vision
of childhood which lifted the child
to the level of a --
a spiritual seer.
Blake claimed that as a four year
old, an angel had appeared to him
in the window of the home
where he was growing up.
He thought that children
had a more direct contact
with the spiritual
realm than adults did.
And, as the kind of founder --
founding figure of Romanticism,
he planted that notion that children
are closer to essential reality
than the adult -- adults are, and
that adults kind of lose contact
with that sort of knowledge by
-- by living a conventional life.
This is something that Blake said
that I think Lewis Carroll
could well identify with.
"The doors of perception
were cleansed.
Everything would appear
to man as it is, infinite,
for man has closed himself
up till he sees all things
through narrow chinks
of his cavern."
When Lewis Carroll was a child, he
was born in 1832, this is a book
that he might well have known.
We don't know if he had a copy then,
but he owned a copy as an adult.
And, he gave this particular copy,
which is at the Rosinback
Library, to a child friend.
Struwwelpeter, German book,
sort of swept through
Europe and North America.
It became a very, very well-known
children's nook in the 1840s.
It was a parody of cautionary tales.
It was meant to allow the child
and the parent to laugh together,
rather than for the parent to
feel that he was lording it
over the child in -- in
instructing the child how to behave.
This book appeared the
following year in England,
Edward Leer's "The Book of
Nonsense", in the same new,
playful spirit that Lewis
Carroll developed even further
in "Alice" 20 years later.
And, this is the parody of
the poem from Isaac Watts.
"How doth the little crocodile
improve his shining tail,
and poured the waters of the
Nile in every golden scale.
How cheerfully he seems to grim.
How neatly spreads his claws,
and welcomes little fishes
in with gently smiling jaws."
Well, nothing very sweet
about that, you know?
And, Alice the character is always
moving away from her good behavior,
the sort of Isaac Watts
version of herself that you meet
at the very beginning of the story
towards someone who's a lot more
curious, more daring, not as nice.
But, more real.
Industrial Revolution was part of
the big change that was happening
that made the Romantics
feel they had to respond.
People were living in terms of
-- thinking in terms of science
and logic and losing
touch with the spiritual
or the sense of wonder in life.
Wordsworth, of course, wrote
about this in this poem.
And, here in this very famous poem,
he resorted to lyricism in a sort
of ecstatic vein, hoping
to connect with people,
to get them to reconnect
themselves with the --
the unseen and the wondrous in life.
He thought that poetry
could do that.
The Surrealists, when they came
around a hundred years later,
would feel that lyricism
wasn't enough,
and decided they needed
shock tactics.
And, surrealism really is all
about a jolt to the system in order
to get people to break out of
their conventional way of thinking
about things, in order to have a --
to be put back in contact
with the sense of the unknown
and the sense of the wondrous.
This really is the visual
counterpart of Wordsworth's poem.
Hans Christian Anderson was
another figure we know of by name
from this time, and
Anderson was writing
as a modern man wonder tales.
And, he was trying to figure
out how you could make a place
for the wonderful in literature
-- literature of the modern age.
And, so he thought perhaps
the way to think about it is
that wonder exists but most
of us just don't notice it.
And, maybe it's just the children
who are a little bit more wide-eye,
as Blake had said, who are
more likely to notice the --
the little creature
living in the flower cup.
And, maybe it's the child who,
being more wide-eyed and honest
with himself, is the one
who's most likely to see
that the emperor has no clothes.
And, the emperor is
naked is not so far
from you're nothing
but a pack of cards.
And, in "Alice" Lewis Carroll
really undermines almost every kind
of authority that a
child was likely to know.
The authority of adults, the
authority of judges and jurors,
the authority of kings and
queens, the authority of logic
and language itself as
words slip in and out
of their conventional meanings.
We don't know exactly
what Lewis Carroll thought
about Charles Darwin, whose "Origin
of Species" appeared six years
before "Alice" did in England.
But, we know that he owned
19 books by or about Darwin.
So, he must have been interested.
And, if you think of the fish
footmen and other characters
that he created and the
portmontowards [phonetic],
which are amalgams of
two different words.
Or, the puns that he
used where one word seems
to mean opposite things
or unrelated things.
And -- or the scene where the baby
turns into a pig all of a sudden.
You see that Lewis Carroll
was fascinated by the prospect
of transformation in
the world, and of the --
the transient nature
of the material world.
Lewis Carroll was a devout
Christian, and Darwin did nothing
to destroy is faith in God.
But, he nonetheless seems to
have been fascinated with this,
and at the very least
thought of natural selection
as ripe material for
parody and humor.
And, certainly some of that
finds its way into "Alice", too.
He was also a reader of the
new literary genre of fantasy.
And, George MacDonald was a
friend, in a way a mentor of his,
it was MacDonald and his
children who read the
"Alice" manuscript before
it was even being considered
for publication and who urged him to
think about turning it into a book.
And, of course, fantasy is also
a kind of story which departs
from reality as described
biblical -- in biblical terms,
but which in a sense puts
the author in the position
of being a subcreator, a little god
who is inventing an
alternate universe,
which is kind of what
Carroll does in "Alice".
As I mentioned before, he was very
open to the theater as another kind
of arena of transformation.
This was a photograph
taken by Lewis Carroll
of the most famous stage
actress of his day, Ellen Terry,
with whom he became a friend.
And, when Lewis Carroll years
later had occasion to write
about the making of "Alice", he
described the scene on the river
in these terms, as a kind of --
time of reverie for
him and improvisation.
Surrealists would look back
at this as an indication
that Lewis Carroll tapped --
had tapped into his unconscious
and that he was doing it in the
way that they aimed to do as well,
to see what would come
to the surface
without exercising any
sort of rational control.
Lewis Carroll is sometimes
thought of as an odd-ball recluse,
but actually he was
a very social being.
He frequently took the train
from Oxford to London to go
to the theater and to
visit art galleries
and to visit his artist friends.
He was close to many of the members
of the Pre-Raphaelites
painter's group,
and was very familiar
with their work.
This is a painting that we know
that he admired, and it's a painting
about a family who are listening
to music and being transported
to a kind of dream-like state.
So, it's very much in line with
the quote I just showed you
of how Lewis Carroll
said that he had come --
come to making up the story
about Alice in the first place.
This is another painting that
we know that he liked very much.
The girl there at first glance
might seem to be the embodiment
of innocence, but at second glance,
she clearly has something
on her mind.
This is a thoughtful,
wide-eyed, deeply aware person.
And, this image of childhood is the
one that interested Lewis Carroll,
and that he carried over
when he made the manuscript
that John was talking
about a moment ago,
"Alice's Adventures Underground",
the precursor to the
Wonderland book.
He had seen this painting
just probably weeks
or months before he
drew this picture.
And, there is how it
looks within the book.
Lewis Carroll was a perfectionist,
and when he was persuaded
to publish the book, he decided that
what he had done as a one-off gift
to a child friend wasn't
good enough.
So, he set about rewriting
and expanding the manuscript
and also engaging the best
illustrator that he could find,
and that was John Tenniel,
who was the lead cartoonist
for Hunch Magazine.
Now, if you look closely at
this image, you'll see --
you'll recognize one
of the characters
in it, to the left of the line.
That is the very first appearance
in print of the character
that we have come to call Alice,
thought his image was done before --
just about a year before the
Alice book was published.
And, probably before Tenniel
knew that this was going
to be his representation of
the heroine of the story.
So, it seems that he had a
kind of back-log of characters
that he could use, and he
happened to plug Alice --
the Alice one into this
image, which is of --
was created for a story
about the America Civil War.
Notice, this is 1864.
So, there's Tenniel, and this
image is a very good representation
of his ability to embrace the
strangeness of the Wonderland story,
but with a sense of humor
so that you don't feel
that the discordant elements,
like the frog which is
also part human are --
are primarily disturbing.
They're more funny than otherwise,
whereas one of Tenniel's
inspirations, JJ Grandfield,
French satirist from
20 years earlier,
clearly had darker ambitions in
terms of the tone that he was trying
to set as he called out
the animal nature of --
on people of pretense
in polite society.
And, here, flashing forward for a
moment, Max Ernst, clearly looking
at Grandfield and probably
Tenniel, too,
used some of the same techniques
to disturb and question reality.
Lewis Carroll, as I mentioned,
was a fine portrait photographer.
This is a photograph that he took
of Alice a few years before
the time of the story.
It's a penetrating image and
probably one of this very best,
and it shows that Carroll was
in a sense a psychologist,
more than a moralist.
And, in fact, you could say that
whereas children's literature
up until that time had been
about building character,
Lewis Carroll was more about
developing characters and showing
that within a given self, a
given individual there are --
this is a kind of rouge's gallery
of characters all competing to be
at the center of the stage.
This Alice clearly has
a deep emotional life,
and I think this photograph,
perhaps more than any other he took,
shows that he was a kind of
forerunner for the things
that Freud would write about
just a few decades later.
Freud, of course, became a major
influence on the Surrealists
because Freud was writing and
giving names to unconscious states
that the Surrealists felt were
the part of human experience
that most people were
not in touch with,
were denying if they
even knew they existed.
And, Freud's interest in dreams
became a kind of inspiration
for the Surrealist to -- to pay
more attention to their own dreams
and to try to tap into
them for artistic purposes.
World War One was also an
enormously disruptive influence
that had a great impact on
the artists that became known
as the Surrealists, because all the
old empires were coming to pieces.
And, it seemed that it was time
for an art that did not aspire
to a grand synthesis,
but rather one that aimed
at breaking people's
certainties into bits.
That's, I think, the
reason that collage became
such an important art medium in
the years after World War One.
And, it's also -- it also gave
the Surrealist a kind of roadmap
for taking images and putting them
together in ways that didn't seem
to belong and for -- for that reason
provoking the kind of puzzled,
short-circuited response
in people's rational mind
that they were really aiming for.
This is Andre Breton, who
was kind of the ringleader
of the Surrealists
and the theoretician.
He wrote the two Surrealist
manifestos,
and this is a very interesting
quote because like Lewis Carroll
and like the Romantics, he looked to
children as having a better purchase
on truth than the adult world did.
I'll read this.
"The mind which plunges
into surrealism relives
with glowing excitement
the best part of childhood.
From childhood memories and from a
few others, there emanates a feeling
of being unintegrated, then
later of having gone astray,
which I hold as the most
fertile that exists.
It is perhaps childhood that
comes closest to one's real self."
If you think about Alice
falling down the rabbit hole,
everything that she thinks
she knows falls away from her,
her school learning, her good
manners, she curtsies as she falls
down the hole, but it
doesn't do her any good.
Language, do cats eat
bats or do bats eat cats.
Suddenly words untethered to reality
become interchangeable she mentions
her cat, you know, her
friend, her companion,
but where is -- where is Dinah.
It was that -- that is
what Breton means, I think,
when he talks about childhood and
the lack of things coming together,
which in a sense is more real.
It's -- it's the opposite of
putting out arbitrary barriers
that make the world seem
reasonable even if at the price
of falsifying the reality.
So, the Surrealists came up
with some very interesting ways
of jolting people back
to that sense of sort
of a truthful disconnectedness.
We sort of take for granted that
words and the images we associate
with them are -- are one.
But, really they aren't
and this painting is meant
to make you rethink everything
you know about language
and the material world and
how they relate to each other
and if nothing else to show that
it's imperfect connection at best.
The Surrealists were very
expressive about their ideas
and in the 1930s Andre Breton listed
out some of the artists and writers
that he considered his precursors.
And, as you read down the list
you find a somewhat puzzling list
and -- and for various reasons.
You find Lewis Carroll
among his forbearers.
The 1930s was a big time
for Lewis Carroll's legacy.
In 1932, the hundredth
anniversary of its birth,
there were almost no celebrations.
It's interesting.
People had forgotten
about him more or less.
A few years later, an effort
was made to change that.
The Complete Works of Lewis
Carroll were published in England
and then in the US in 1936.
And, there were major
exhibitions in England, France,
and the US of Surrealism, all
of which made some reference
to Lewis Carroll as
having been an inspiration.
This is the poster from
the British exhibition.
And, this is the one from New
York's Museum of Modern Art,
which this drawing from
"Alice's Adventures
in Underground" was
exhibited, and which appears
to have influenced
Max Ernst, I think,
when he came to make
drawings inspired
by Lewis Carroll a
number of years later.
Probably the artist who was closest
you might say to Lewis Carroll,
and in some ways the closest
to being an illustrator
of Lewis Carroll was Rene Magritte.
And, I thought it would be fun to
show you how one can actually think
of Rene Magritte as having
illustrated Alice, whether
or not he was trying to consciously.
It would be very surreal of him to
have done it unconsciously, in fact.
So, here's one of my favorite
Magritte paintings and it calls
to mind an essay, or actually kind
of math puzzle, mind experiment
that Lewis Carroll wrote having
to do with the time zones.
And, Lewis Carroll was actually
partly responsible for the creation
of the International Dateline,
because he began to think
about the consequences of
having different time zones
around the globe and how at a
certain point, it becomes yesterday
and today at the same
-- in the same place.
And, how do you make sense of that?
And, it was -- creating an arbitrary
line like that which became the way
for the world to -- to make some
sense, some imperfect sense.
His essay was called
"Where Does the Day Begin?"
This is the scene where
Alice is growing
and growing inside of
the lizard's house.
It seems very much to have
been in the background
of this painting by Magritte.
And, here's the passage.
"Still, she kept on growing.
As a last resource, she put
one arm out of the window,
one foot up the chimney, and said
to herself, 'Now, I can do no more.
Whatever happens, what will become
of me?'" Here's Alice puzzling
over this bottle wondering
whether to believe the tag or not.
Think of that painting
of Magritte's pipe.
[Inaudible] it's colored
because this comes
from a later abridged edition
done for younger children
in the nursery [inaudible].
And, here again, Magritte
is playing games with words
and images associated with them.
You know, for the bowler
hat for instance,
the caption in French means snow.
So, he's saying -- but
in a sense, you know,
the words that he chose are just
as good as labels for those objects
as the ones that we
conventionally would apply to them,
which is part of his point.
The arbitrary nature
of the relationship
between language and reality.
It's very well to say drink me,
but the wise little Alice was
not going to do that in a hurry.
No, I'll look first, she said
and she whether it's
marked poison or not.
Smart child.
Here is the caterpillar, the
kind of implacable wise man.
And, here is Magritte
looking through you.
Who are you?
And, here is Alice holding a pig
that had only moments before
had been a human baby,
and she's puzzling
over what happened.
This is [inaudible], not Magritte,
but who wasn't really a
Surrealist but he was pretty close.
"The baby grunted again.
This time there could
be no mistake about it.
It was neither more
nor less than a pig.
She began thinking over
other children she knew
who might do very well as pigs.
She was just saying to herself,
if one only knew the
right way to change them."
What a wicked sense of humor.
Which way?
And, here the famous Mad Tea Party
scene, tea parties being occasions
of domesticity genteel
social behavior.
And, this Surrealist object by
Meret Oppenheim from the 1930s,
where tea cup and what goes
with it has been transformed
into a feral object, something
wild, meant to be shocking and meant
to kind of knock you off your
pedestal of social certainty.
And, the Cheshire Cat.
"Well, I've often seen a cat
without a grin, thought Alice.
But a grin without a cat, it's
the most curious thing I ever saw
in all my life."
A number of the Surrealists
took a shot
at at least making one-off paintings
inspired directly by "Alice".
I think they were by and large
self-consciously eroticized versions
of what they kind of perhaps
felt superior to when they --
to the extent that they looked
at it as a children's book.
So, I think, like this
painting for instance,
I just don't find all
that convincing.
Maybe this one's a little bit
better by Dorothy Tanning.
And, this by -- when Rene Magritte
actually tried to illustrate Alice,
I think that's when he
didn't quite pull it off.
Salvador Dali did his
own addition, though,
and I've been looking at it lately.
And, the more I look at it
the more I -- I like it.
It's very different from the art by
him that we're more familiar with,
the hyper-realistic paintings
where perspectives are distorted
and certain images are called
up as compelling symbols
like melting watches for example.
It's much more Impressionistic,
but it --
the images exist on many levels,
and it has almost the quality
of a dream image that
you're able to peer into.
And, I think that's what
he was probably aiming for.
This is the title page,
and this girl --
woman with the jump rope becomes
his Alice in the kind of motif
that reappears everywhere
in unexpected places.
This is a -- is a painting
that he would have known
and clearly was affected
by, by de Chirico.
And, here's a painting
by Dali in which you see
that figure appearing way --
long before he illustrated Alice.
But, here -- and here
is a picture from --
from his book, from,
I think it's 1969.
The more you look at
this, the more you see,
and it's not just one reality.
There are many layers that
have been brought together
in a way that only dreams can do.
And, finally, this sculpture
from Mexico City based
on the poem parody of Isaac Watts.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
So, we have time for some questions.
We have ten minutes,
if anybody would
like to ask one, or make a comment.
Yeah. Yes?
>> I'm interested in your thoughts
on the intersection between fantasy
and surreal, because you've
shown us a bit of both.
But, I'm interested in that notion
of representation and the --
the idea of fantasy, which I
think Carroll was interested in
and this idea of something
that's beyond that maybe tapping
into the unconscious mind.
Just interested in how you see
the difference [inaudible].
>> You -- you're interested
in the difference
between fantasy and Surrealism?
Well, I think fantasy -- I mean
the Surrealists were interested
in dreams and I think they thought
of dreams as a productive fantasy
that is generated by
the human unconscious.
So, I'm not sure that they would
have tried to make a distinction
so much as to see dream life as
a subset of fantasy, I suppose.
Yeah. I mean, the Surrealists
were interested in --
in operating with as little control
over their artistic
process as possible.
So -- so I suppose you could
make a distinction because,
like JRR Tolkien talked
about writing fantasy
as being a subcreator as -- as
stepping into the role of a god.
So, now, as I -- I'm sort
of thinking as I speak,
and it seems to me that you
could make the case that fantasy
and Surrealism were opposed
to each other in that sense.
You know, to the extent that
the Surrealist really wanted
to cede control and that that was
essential to what they saw as the --
the way to getting at
sort of the deepest truth.
And, that would the
opposite of someone
who builds an alternate universe.
Yeah.
>> I had a quick question
about the [inaudible].
I'm over here.
>> Leonard Marcus: You're over here.
Okay. Yeah.
>> About Carroll, I know your
focus was on the Surrealists,
but you kind of zoomed passed
the futurists, and I was curious,
do your thoughts about the
connection with playing
with the actually depiction
of language and words,
and any other connections
and impressions
that -- with the futurists.
>> Leonard Marcus: I
-- I -- you know, I --
I don't know as much
about the futurists.
I mean, I know -- I know something.
But, sounds like perhaps you want
what [inaudible] say something
about that though.
>> I've forgotten the
technical term for when you --
when you depict a language moving.
Like, Carroll perhaps was one of the
first ones to use that in his work.
>> Leonard Marcus: In the way of
concrete poetry where with the --
the image of the tail
in the shape of the-- .
>> -- Yes.
And, that was something that the
futurists enjoyed and I wondered
if there were other types
of connections with Carroll
and possibly the futurists.
>> Leonard Marcus: Offhand,
I -- I just don't know.
>> Okay.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yeah.
So, yes, sir?
>> [Inaudible] kind of
subgenre, books, fiction,
works of art in all forms about
Alice, and a [inaudible] of tones
and from the innocent to the
horrific, especially it seems
in the -- lately by women authors.
And, they're more fascinated
by Alice.
And, I was wondering why Alice
has become such a fertile source
of inspiration for these
writers and artists.
>> Well, I mean, I think there's
something every basically true
about his representation of her.
You see, too, in a way two opposing
aspects of a developing human.
You see the social self, the one
who has learned certain lessons
about how to behave among other
people at the very beginning.
And, then she falls
down the rabbit hole
where it all becomes irrelevant, and
she's suddenly put in the position
of really any -- you know,
hero in the classic sense.
Somebody who's completely
on their own
in an unknown, uncharted situation.
So, I mean, her -- her quest, it
is a quest in a way, you know.
Like, Ulysses, it's --
there's something very --
there's a core reality to -- to the
experience that she goes through
and it's a beautiful way of
describing the experience
of childhood and growing
up and just being human.
You know, we talk about growing up.
Alice grows up, down, this
way, that way, and really her,
you know multidirectional fits and
starts experience is much truer
to what anybody who's being honest
with themselves would report
as the true nature of, you know,
living and learning in this world.
So, and, I mean, we're -- we're
always being put upon by people
who think they know
better than we are,
and that happens to
Alice all the time.
And, she has to cope with situations
where the consequences are serious
and the choices are unclear.
You know, should she drink from
that bottle or shouldn't she?
People she has been taught to
expect good things from turn out not
to be helpful or wise
or even friendly.
So, there's so much reality in
this apparent nonsense, you know.
The nonsense just becomes a way
of in a sense making it
bearable and interesting.
It's -- it's a deeply
realistic book, I think.
So, yeah?
>> [Inaudible] as you're talking
that her process really
is the process of science.
And, there's a reason
-- there's a reason
that Martin Gardener was a
mathematician did an annotated book.
And -- but I wonder if you know,
and I haven't looked at that
because it didn't connect,
but the OSS Science
and Engineering Festival happens
to be meeting in town this weekend.
And, you know, with all of the
talk about STEM this and STEM
that for education, Alice
is the perfect embodiment
of the scientific process and
kind of a mental way into people
who immediately tune out when
you say the word science.
And, I'm wondering whether there's
been any connection made in that way
to -- to try to use Alice,
particularly for children.
>> Well, I mean, there's a book
called "Alice in Numberland",
you know, where the
mathematical ideas that-- .
>> But, beyond math, sort of as
you're talking about, you know,
the fits and starts, that's
what research and sort
of discover is all about.
>> Leonard Marcus: I see.
I see. Yeah.
>> You know, maintaining the
child mind of curiosity-- .
>> Leonard Marcus: -- I see.
Yeah-- .
>> -- To make discoveries.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yeah,
that's interesting.
So much has been written about
Alice that I would be willing to bet
that someone has written about that.
But -- but I mean, he of
course was a scientist
as well as an artist himself.
And, so he kind of brought
together within him different ideas
about truth, you know,
measuring truth
that were available in his time.
Yeah. No -- no, I think
you're right.
Yeah. I -- I wish I could
have been, you know,
sat at one of his math classes.
It might have been very interesting.
But, he spoke with a stutter and
I have a feeling he didn't feel
that comfortable in
front of an audience.
Yeah.
>> Lewis has one of the very best
descriptions of weightlessness
as "Sylvia and Bruno",
with [inaduibnle].
>> Leonard Marcus: Okay.
It was just said that in a
later book of his called "Sylvia
and Bruno", he gave -- Lewis
Carroll gave what is described
as the best description
of weightlessness.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, do you think that "Alice in
Wonderland" is a children's book?
>> Leonard Marcus: I think the best
children's books are for everybody.
So, that's a slightly
different -- I'm --
I'm sort of rewriting
your question in a sense.
We -- we live in a less
literary time than he did.
The character Alice has studied
French at the age of seven,
and I think knows a little
bit of Latin as well.
You know, think how many
seven year old you know
about whom you could say that.
I mean, there would
be some of course.
But, I think it's -- today,
it's a book that children
who are good readers are likely
to read at a slightly older age
than Victorian children would have.
>> [Inaudible].
>> Leonard Marcus: You never know.
>> John Cole: Please, wait
until the microphone gets
to you, if you [inaudible].
>> Leonard Marcus: All right.
The question is is "Alice" really
a children's book, and I'm saying
that it probably -- readers, young
readers today would be older --
somewhat older if you can make
a generalization than the ones
who read it when it was
new in Victorian England
because of the way the culture
and education have changed.
And, also we're Americans,
and British English is not
exactly the same thing, either.
But, I also think that it's as
much a book for some children
as it is a book for some adults.
>> I'm -- would be interested in
your comments on Alice's sister --
Alice's sister who comforts her
when she's back above ground,
but dismisses her experience
I think.
Do you -- do you have
a take on that?
>> Leonard Marcus: I never
sensed that about it.
To -- on what basis
do you think that?
What is it she say that -- I mean,
it's true that she's presented
as a little bit insensitive at
the beginning in that she's --
Alice is bored by the
book, you know,
that she offers her to look at.
But, that's not at all surprising.
I mean, it just shows you that -- it
-- it's just setting the story up,
you know, for Alice to be
more on her own, and to be --
to follow her own curiosity
and her own impulses, I think.
You know, and it's her saying
the boring adults, you know?
Children know more.
It's -- it's really the Romantic
view of the child right there.
You know, she's reading some
boring book, doesn't have pictures,
doesn't have conversations.
What good is it?
>> Do you know anything about
the author of Mary Poppin's books
and whether she was
influenced by Lewis Carroll?
>> Leonard Marcus: Yeah,
PL Travers, no doubt.
Yeah. "Alice" was enormously
popular and I think everybody
who was interested in children's
book as a reader let alone
as a writer would have
-- would have read it.
I mean, she -- PL Travers
was kind of a mystic.
I mean, she was interested
in mythology, too.
You know, so she had
other -- other influences.
She saw Mary Poppins really as a
kind of supernatural goddess figure.
And, the Disney version
is really very different
from what she had in mind.
So, it's, you know, you can't
make a kind of -- it's the --
exactly the same world
that she's interested
in that Lewis Carroll
was interested.
But, certainly there was
an affinity I would think.
Yeah, sir?
>> Talked a little bit about the
Realists and the Pre-Raphaelites,
and you contrasted
that the Surrealists.
Wondering if you see some
similarities, either in terms
of what the message was
that they were trying
to convey or the artistic styles.
>> Leonard Marcus: Well, I mean,
the Pre-Raphaelites seem to be,
maybe they wouldn't have
said so, but they seemed
to have been interested
in the dream realm,
you know, in the spiritual realm.
And, you know, you could
certainly say the same thing
about some of the Surrealists, too.
Yeah. Yes, I think so.
I mean, they weren't
interested in the Pre-Raphael --
Pre-Raphaelites were masters
of realistic technique,
but they weren't interested
in just painting things, like,
you know, fruit on the table.
They -- they were trying to
get in some spiritual essence
that lay beyond the visible.
And, to that extent, I mean,
they, the Surrealists were trying
to catapult people
out of the mundane.
Yeah. Yes?
>> Yes, what are your -- right here.
>> Leonard Marcus: Okay, yeah, it's
hard to -- it's impossible to tell.
>> What are your top three most
surreal aspects of the "Alice" book?
>> Leonard Marcus: Well, one
would be -- there's several, like,
fade-out, fade-ins that
connect some of the same things.
You know, the way they --
there's a kind of dream logic
to the way the story unfolds.
So, that would be one of them.
That's distracting.
Surreal.
>> [Inaudible].
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes, I know.
I know. I mean, the -- the
unreliability of language,
which comes up in the form of
puns which are misunderstood
and which sometimes redirect
the action in surprising ways
with the queen, you know threatening
to decapitate people, for example.
And, with all the misunderstanding
that arise as a result of that.
And, I think the fact
that Alice as --
is the character who turns
out to be the most knowing.
And, that conforms with
what Andre Breton had said
about the ideal state really
that Surrealism was aiming
to put its viewers or its
audience in was a state of-- .
-- A sort of -- of a more
fractured understanding
of the -- of the world.
I mean, I think he --
the Surrealists thought that
people had everything much too pat,
you know?
And, he wanted to break it up,
they wanted to break it up for them
so they would see the fragmentary
and inconclusive nature of reality.
And, Alice -- that is
Alice's experience,
more than anybody else's.
everybody else is pretty sure
of themselves in that book.
So, yeah.
>> John Cole: We have time
for two more questions.
>> Leonard Marcus: These are
good questions, by the way.
I feel -- yeah?
>> John Cole: Let's
wait for the microphone.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes.
Over here.
Yep?
>> I noticed, and I was just curious
whether it had occurred to you
that a painting that you pointed out
of the little girl in bed, you know,
with the -- her head
cocked and the, you know?
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes.
Yep.
>> And, the shoulder showing.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes.
>> And -- and then the
gypsy Alice, the photograph.
>> Leonard Marcus: Right.
Right.
>> Is that -- do you
think that influenced him.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes-- .
>> -- Because it's such
a lovely parallel there.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes, absolutely.
>> And, almost like the way he
would see her in his mind's eye.
>> Leonard Marcus: Right.
Absolutely.
I mean, when Lewis Carroll
saw a painting that he liked,
and that was the case
with the one that I showed
with the family listening to music,
he brought those people together
and photographed them in that pose.
I mean, he was -- that's
how methodical he was
and how connected he felt or moved
he felt by certain images, you know?
So, absolutely.
Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] take the photograph
and that was the painting
that you're referring to-- .
>> Leonard Marcus: -- Right-- .
>> -- Was 1864.
>> Leonard Marcus: Right.
Well, in that particular example,
but in the example I just gave,
he photographed it after
seeing the painting.
So, it's -- what my point -- it's --
it's that this kind of
relationship interested him.
Right. I mean, it may be
coincidental in that case,
but on the other hand there may
be other images that predate,
which would be just the same.
>> [Inaudible] painting copied
as a photo with Isa Bowman.
>> Leonard Marcus: Okay.
Yeah. Thank you.
One more, I think.
Or, have we come to the end.
>> John Cole: There's
got to be one more.
>> Leonard Marcus: Right.
Make it -- make it a hard one.
>> John Cole: Here we go.
[Inaudible].
>> Leonard Marcus: These
have been too easy.
>> Excellent, excellent
talk, Leonard.
>> Leonard Marcus: Thank you, yeah.
Thank you.
>> I don't really have a
question but just a comment
on the lady's question, the lady
who was sitting in front of me
but has disappeared
like the Cheshire Cat.
She asked about the mouse's
tail and the kind of --
the concrete poetry [inaudible]
there is a technical term.
It's called technopaegnia,
unstructured play, if you will,
which sums up Carroll in a phrase.
>> Leonard Marcus: Yes.
Very good.
Thank you.
Yeah. Great.
>> John Cole: Well, please join me
in thanking Leonard
for a wonderful talk.
[ Applause ]
Leonard, it was really excellent,
and it was a talk that stretched you
and stretched the audience,
I think, a little bit.
And, just opened up the yet one
more layer of the world of Alice
and the various manuscripts.
You're going to now -- there
are two places we'd like you
to go if you haven't been.
One would be upstairs, which I
referred to at the beginning.
It's in the Rare Book and
Special Collections Division
in the Rosenwald Room, and I'll be
happy to lead a group to upstairs
to the back if you -- we
could just gather in --
in the foyer as we go out.
But, also the other placed I'd
mentioned is the Young Readers
Center, which is in this building,
a completely different direction.
You'll get a chance to follow
Kaheed is there and you can go
down a secret staircase
that's not quite secret,
but nonetheless a little surreal.
And, visit the Young Readers
Center where there are also,
I learned today, copies of books
with annotations from the Rare Book
and Special Collections
Division upstairs.
So, it's a nice example of pulling
out the collections that we have
and you'll see a wonderful
array and display
of formats and content as well.
But, thanks for joining us,
and another round of applause
for Leonard Marcus
for a terrific job.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.